foreign
[Music]
49 we're going to get a serious opponent
and we have white against small fish
1998 not to be confused with big fish
1995 that's Vladimir fedes let's go with
our traditional repertoire okay
okay my friend let's see where where
this goes because
okay now
at this point I don't know
if this is what he does every game
and tries to win it but right now I have
absolutely no comment now I will say
that we faced stuff like this at a lower
level like if you remember the obviously
when we start the speedrun we're facing
total beginners so it's not like we
haven't faced this kind of line before
now you might roll your eyes at this
watching on YouTube but it is good to
know how to actually punish
troll lines like this now I I'm assuming
that our opponent isn't gonna go like
King G6 and get himself checkmated maybe
he's just throwing the game deliberately
but if he's not and if he goes like E6
and stuff then it is good to know how to
arrange your pieces to maximize your
potential against lines like these
because a lot of people really they do
struggle and they don't know when to try
to go for it and when to develop the
general rule of thumb that I like to go
by is you can't get anything done unless
you develop your pieces so there might
be a Temptation here to go Queen H5
check or even Bishop C4 check and I
don't love either of these moves
because Queen H5 runs into G6 and we
haven't achieved anything Bishop C4 runs
into E6 which is a move that black wants
to play anyway so I would start with
what I always call the most flexible
developing move what is a move that you
know is not going to hurt you some of
you may be thinking C4 to grab more of
the center that's a legitimate move but
I like Knight C3 start with the queen
side development okay and E6 is
pre-moved I could have also played D5 by
the way would have been an ANSI pre-move
now
we have to decide where to develop this
bishop and C4 is a pretty good Square
I actually think given what our opponent
just did C4 I'm starting to change my
mind on Bishop C4 because the idea that
I'm starting to pick up on is to follow
up with the D5 and blast open the center
and that of course is the general rule
for playing against troll openings is
you develop your pieces you blast open
the center and then you go for checkmate
that's kind of the formula if you wanted
to play this more solidly we could play
Bishop D3 even Bishop B2 is fine but I
think we should try to maximize our
potential in this position and go Bishop
C4
importantly D5 is impossible because we
have three Defenders on that square
and we're already loading up
a move like D5 and you should look at
this and it should be clear to you why
D5 is such a dangerous threat because
just look at this diagonal Black's Queen
is currently undefended so D5 would
threaten Pawn takes E6 check obviously D
takes C6 blunders the queen
if black plays Knight C6 and tries to
defend the queen then D5 comes with
Tempo and chases the Knight away from C6
so it's actually not so easy for black
to defend this queen
so very simple we developed two pieces
we're holding off on the development of
our other pieces and this is the
opposite extreme which you should also
not adopt you should not assume that you
have to develop every single piece
before you can start to punish these
types of openings it really depends on
how your opponent follows up so here
we're at a Crossroads we could play D5 I
think Bishop before is the best move
then our opponent responds probably with
Knight to E7 and he is in time to
connect the rook and the queen so my
intuition says that D5 here might be a
little bit premature
instead I think we should shift back to
the developmental side of things
and finish off our King side development
now this move when we haven't yet
developed our Knight is very effectively
met with Knight to E2 I really like the
look of 92 because it connects the
knights it takes the sting out of Bishop
takes C3 and if black later pushes D5
then we could deploy this Knight to F4
in order to pressure that weak spot on
D5 so that's one option what else can we
do we could play D5 97 and then play
Knight E2 that's also an eminent
possibility and as a matter of fact one
thing that gives me pause is that if we
play 92 black actually can play D5
because then after we take and take we
cannot take because after Queen D5 the
Knight is pinned and what worries me is
after 92 D5 let's say takes takes Bishop
B3 black pushes C6 and really closes off
the light squared bishop and then black
can proceed by continuing to develop his
King side so actually when I look at
this a little bit more deeply it occurs
to me that D5 is what we could call a
positional threat
and it can be prevented by pushing D5
ourselves and staking a larger claim in
the center let's go for it and let's
follow this up with rapid development
yeah D5 just feels it felt premature to
me originally but then I I realized that
black actually wants to play D5
and that's what changed my mind now I
feel like we should play this move
before continuing our development
now what you're seeing is that it is
actually actually is not easy for a
human to punish this type of opening
like I'm really not sure if I'm playing
this well I think I'm obviously playing
this decently we're still much better
but when you check these types of lines
with a computer the computer always
gives these crazy setups and it's almost
impossible to play positions like this
totally accurately so what you need to
do is say okay I'm probably not going to
win the game out of the opening
but my goal is to get a solid middle
game advantage and don't excoriate
yourself for not winning in five moves
this is like the biggest thing where you
face an opening like this and you just
assume that it has to be winning in six
moves
um and that's not actually the case it
is harder to punish these openings than
it seems they don't lose by force
they're terrible but the evaluation
could be plus two it's not plus six
okay so now
we should decide where we developed this
Knight and as I've already said I really
like the look of 92. why do I like the
look of 92 well there's many reasons one
of which I have already underscored
which is that it connects the knights
Bishop takes C3 no longer ruins our Pawn
structure that's a nice little bonus
what else well I've also pointed out
that the Knight can jump out to F4 why
is that a good idea because the E6 Pawn
is a big soft spot why is it a big soft
spot because we're pressuring it why are
we pressuring it because we're trying to
make it push and if black pushes of
course D6 is a discovery and it's hard
for black to remedy this issue because
if black tries to go D6 then of course
we take on E6 and that's terrible
in fact we could even consider Knight F4
here to try to discourage King G8 okay
but I don't think we should hurry with
that I think we should play castles
still keeping an eye on the Move E5 the
last thing we want to we the thing we do
not want to allow at any cost is for
black to play E5 and D6 because then
when the center closes up the value of
each individual Tempo diminishes greatly
this is a well-known rule where when the
center is closed and gummed up by pawns
you often can afford to move the same
piece like five times because there's no
head-to-head contact between the pieces
most of the time which is why we need to
keep the center at least partially open
and we need to maintain the pressure on
E6 to prevent black a from playing D6
and B we need to make sure that we have
something planned against E5
now King G8 is the obvious move here
completing the castle by hand what is
giving our opponent reservations is the
fact that we can win a pawn we can play
d-e-d-e and then we can jump out to F4
with a knight
and I think we're able to win a very
important Pawn alternatively it might be
smarter to start with Knight F4
I think it is smarter to start with that
F4
yeah I mean there we've got an amazing
position
really both options are good but I like
starting with that F4 because it keeps
the Queens on the board for the time
being
now after Knight F4 black and play
Bishop takes C3
and there we can oh my gosh D takes C6
there's D5
that's a cool line I'll show after the
game let me try to evaluate something
just a moment
one of the hardest things is choosing
between two lines that both look equally
amazing there is some calculation I have
to do here so just give me a moment
there's sort of the Russian Schoolboy
method here
and then there's the like I want to go
for the kill method
my inclination is to adopt the Russian
Schoolboy method
on the other hand that other line also
looks
this is going to be very instructive
analysis because I actually am
struggling to compare these things
yeah so let's go D first
I will explain after the game exactly
what my reservation was about Knight F4
there are some sexy tactics there and
some lines that come out of nowhere
so maybe Knight F4 was the better move
but this just seems so juicy to me I
mean look at the pressure that we have
on E6 now if black trades Queens then we
get a rook to an open file it's not
ideal to trade Queens but if we can win
the E6 model okay so our opponent isn't
even put up a fight here he just gives
up E6 which is sort of the first step
now we actually win material now how do
we want to do this
so I would take a couple of seconds
right to make sure that you're not just
automatically grabbing the pawn because
the pawn on E6 isn't really going
anywhere we could consider a move like
Queen to G4 but Queen tg4 walks into 95
which I think is a little bit annoying
now Bishop takes E6 could appeal to you
because you might be like oh Bishop b696
is a fork but remember black can take on
D1 on demand
and after Rook takes D1 we are in that
position attacking the rook and the pawn
on C7 so that's a great option the other
great option is to play Knight takes C6
and essentially secure the bishop pair
and as a bonus it actually keeps the
Queens on the board because if after 96
black plays Queen takes D1 then we can
First Take The Rook that is a discover
check then pick up the queen with an
extra exchange I think both options are
fantastic here this is largely a matter
of taste again the Russian Schoolboy
method is Bishop takes C6 but you know
this is the nariditski school so we're
gonna go Knight takes C6
okay Bishop takes C6 we're gonna go
Bishop E6 now we have an interesting
situation where again our options are
litany in number we can do like five or
six different things but there is a move
which really really catches my eye
because a it prevents a queen trade B it
really loads up the pressure in the
center yeah 95 this is just such a
natural move
because it solves so many of our
problems at once and if plec takes on D5
we can take back with a pawn and this
bishop is just a bone in Black's throat
it's also setting up some mating ideas
because it prevents the king from
escaping so far into the future I'm
already thinking of a potential work
lift it's not as remote a possibility as
it may seem right it's just like three
moves away Rook on H3 and then we've got
these sort of
mating patterns Queen D6 good move
that's a great move actually by our
opponent
um can we go Queen G4 here and protect
this bishop I want to keep this bishop
on E6 if possible
yeah Bishop F4 blunder is the bishop
don't forget the bishop is hanging
now we could play Knight takes Bishop
but then black can eliminate our Bishop
we're still up a pawn there but we
haven't squeezed the most out of the
position
oh actually Queen G4 might be a blunder
oh my gosh there's a crazy tactic Queen
G4 there might be F5
oh my gosh I almost missed that
so we need a little change of plans I
think we need to bring our Bishop back
or go C3 but C3 is too tactical yeah we
need to move our Bishop back ah we can
also go Knight F4
try to trade Queens Knight F4 is not
half bad
Bishop H3 is very solid but then Black
Goes Rook a to d8 then we go Bishop f495
C3
man he's defending well
maybe I should have gone for the other
approach
no Knight F4 G5 is not dangerous we can
take the queen
yeah Knight F4 does look very very
promising let's go fortnite F4
let's go drop the Knight back to F4 and
so maybe in retrospect Knight D5 is
impulsive I think it was impulsive
because of Queen D6 I completely missed
this move I somehow assumed black had to
take
so probably in this position it would
have been a better idea to just develop
a piece that's always the case it's
always better to just develop Bishop E3
was definitely the best move still we're
dominating here okay I like the fact
that black trades Queens because he
gives us the D file we don't want to
give away the D file which Narrows our
options down to one obviously we want to
bring our Bishop out completing our
development and connecting the Rooks
this is just an automatic move
this should be this should be just habit
for you right you have the battle over a
single open file so generally don't want
to give it up
and so we develop and connect the Rooks
no this guy is not smart somebody says
small just a smurfing gym yeah he's he's
like 2300 blitz so it makes sense
I think he might be a speed run Watcher
because I haven't seen any 15-minute
games in his game in history but her
game history but yeah anyways
so what is it that we want to do here
and as I've discussed before when you
get an end game like this our advantage
is defined by like three main things the
biggest things that we're up upon second
biggest thing is that we have the bishop
air and our pieces are overwhelmingly
better placed third thing is that we
have better control of the center
because we have a pawn in the center and
black doesn't so we need to harness all
three of these advantages in a kind of
patient Manner and keep accumulating but
again these types of end games are never
one or rarely one quickly so you
shouldn't be trying to deliver some
knockout blow I think we should go back
to D5 that seems to be a promising
that's where the the cool kids are at
Knight T5 is just safe and secure and
very strong and now F6 is a weak Pawn as
well
so black is starting to crumble here at
the seams
Bishop D6 good move okay
so now I think it's time to play
something very patient here
that improves our position in a Marginal
Way and keeps the tension I feel like
that's what Magnus would do and these
are the hardest moves for me as a as a
teacher the type of move that I am about
to play is kind of the hardest to unders
to to explain because when you look at a
move like this you might say well I
don't understand exactly what it
accomplishes and there's a lot of moves
like this I don't know which one to make
you can make some Luft with a move like
G3 I like the look of C3 because it
really restricts the Knight and it
prevents things like Bishop E5 which
would no longer come with a threat
against B2
so I really like the look of a move like
C3 or even H3 actually even H4 comes to
mind because if black takes we have
Bishop to H6 actually H4 looks great
here and that's a more concrete move
yeah the reason I don't like C4 is
because after Bishop E5 we create a
small hole on D4 so maybe C4 is good
also but that's actually part of why I
wanted to play C3
um no there's a bunch there's like a
million moves here
I really like the idea of driving this
planet down to H5 let's start with H4
this is the Tactical solution but
I'm liking what I'm seeing here oh so
after H6 which is likely
I actually think
that we should take here
you see I also struggle in the
conversion phase of these types of end
games the only guy who doesn't is Magnus
so again there's like C3 now the appeal
of takes is that we open up the H file
in the appeal of opening up the H files
that we can quite easily get a rook to
H1 what is the typical method who can
tell me and I'm going to have to speed
up a little bit here of when you have a
situation like this and you have a king
blocking The Rook this is kind of a
stock idea that you should be familiar
with not really yeah F3 King F2 but that
weakens some dark squares it's a better
idea to go G3 because this is a healthy
move anyway it like restricts the bishop
a little bit and it doesn't ruin the
structural Integrity of the center then
the idea would be king G2 and Rook H1
and with Queens on the board this is
much more effective now what should we
take with another difficult decision I'm
inclined to take with the bishop
actually
which might strike you as quite
counterintuitive I think a lot of you
want to take with a pawn that's what
you're itching to play
okay but anyways I'll talk about it
later 95 is very good by our opponent
now I think we should complete our idea
with King G2
now Bishop takes B7
is met with Rook B8 which I don't like
the look of because that gives black a
lot of activity after he recaptures on
B2 on the other hand there are some
tactics there that could work in our
favor so Bishop takes B7 Rook B8 Bishop
back to D5
Rook takes B2 and does anybody see what
move is really appealing to me about
that line
it's Bishop back to B3 The Rook on B2 is
trapped and we can attack it probably
through Bishop C1
it's a little bit risky to do that
because we're compromising our activity
but I think it works out let's go for it
Bishop takes B7 I think he has to go
Rook B8 I don't see another move here
for black maybe maybe I'm wondering
something but I don't see another move
here
now that's a huge Pawn because that's
not only a pawn it also ruins the entire
Queen side so if we can get away with
this we win the game
okay so our opponent is just not
reacting to that and now I think we
should just drop the bishop back
maybe we can get away with taking a
third Pawn but remember the law of
diminishing returns of Chess material
the more material you're up the less
value each subsequent unit of material
me is which means you shouldn't contort
yourself to take an additional Pawn if
you're already two pawns up Bishop A7 I
maybe would play in classical but I
would have to calculate it and make sure
we're not losing any of our Bishops
so I think we should focus instead on
evacuating first and foremost our Bishop
away from the Danger Zone on B7 back
into the center
then we should complete our initial idea
which is to play King G2 yeah obviously
our opponent wants this crap
with G4 this is what I think he wants
but it doesn't threaten anything right
very important knots if you're a ghost
because even if black had rook h8 in we
could just meet it with Rook H1 but
let's beat Black to the punch and go
Rook H1 ourselves in order to try to
initiate a trade of all of the Rooks
which would bring us one step closer to
Victory also at this point we can
already take A7 essentially at our
convenience we can take it now the one
reservation I have about Bishop takes A7
is a move like C5 which locks the bishop
out a little bit but in that position we
could already start pushing the pawn so
this is a matter of taste we could play
Rook hate rook h8 and Rook H1
alternatively we could play Bishop takes
A7 here and win the third pawn and
basically win the game
yeah I don't see
a reason not to let's take another Pawn
now you might say well I don't didn't
you just say law of diminishing returns
yes but that doesn't mean you don't take
stuff that's completely free right if it
just hangs
and you can take it then take it
especially because this actually is the
first move which creates a past Pawn
notice that we still don't have a passer
here so our two extra pawns aren't quite
as felt once we take A7 that's it we get
a pass pawn and we can push it it's a
nice one
C6 our opponent trying to go for some
activity here Bishop takes C6 I don't
even understand what he wants to be
honest
after Bishop C6 I also like Bishop E6
which might be even better
yeah I like Bishop E6 because then we're
trying to disarm this mechanism which is
Black's last source of activity right
the last source of annoyance is the
placement of this Knight on F3
and at this point we have eaten our fill
and I think we should actually stick the
bishop on E6 and try to disarm the
source of this mechanism which is the
undefended Pawn on G4
then our general strategy is just to
start pushing the a pawn when we get a
chance keeping an eye on the possibility
of trading Rooks which our opponent is
doing for us
absolutely
now notice that this does not attack H2
I saw that
maybe our opponent will take it out of
desperation but yeah now it's now it's
just a matter of very straightforward
technique nothing's nothing fancy
or B8 nice trickery by our opponent
after Bishop takes G4 he wants to drop
the Knight back to E5
and then ah but we can revert to our old
oh this is actually really pretty yeah
let's do it let's take
four pawns up and look at what I'm about
to do so he wants 95 that's an ingenious
defensive idea we go back to E6
and we borrow an older idea of trapping
The Rook with Bishop E6 back to B3 which
is an idea that you should absolutely be
familiar with where like the bishop
guards two Pawns
you have a rook that guards the first
Rank and then there's another piece such
as the King to deliver the crushing blow
we have a very pretty tactic here that
wins the game this is really pretty does
anybody see a way to actually get to
this Rook because you might say oh well
Bishop D4 isn't a move anymore what
about Bishops you want Bishop C1 doesn't
seem to work because of Rook B1 but then
the Rooks are aligned the king is on a
dark square and this is why I didn't
give this check at an earlier point
right because I noticed that the King
was in a dark Square you have to keep
those types of moves in your pocket it's
all very easy we're up three pawns like
it's all very pedantic but it's still
quite a nice way to end the game and
this is how you how you punish these
types of openings it took us the length
of a regular game right it wasn't five
moves it wasn't ten moves but we got
that early Advantage we kept
accumulating it and black really never
got out of the gates our opponent is
provisional so I think his real strength
is closer to 1800 or 1900 but definitely
not lower than that our opponent found
some good moves let's take a look
so
in your experience playing you are gonna
face a bunch of these troll openings
right and they've gotten more popular
it's a bond Cloud what else is there
like F3 King F2 which we faced some
people play like F5 this is I think
called the Fred
I think this is the Fred
or is the Fret no the Fred actually is
F6 maybe it's also called the Barnes
defense because I know Barnes played
this against morphe I'm not a big
specialist in in names now F5 actually
is not as bad of a move as you might
think it is this move I've struggled to
refute the point is it's almost like a
reverse king's Gambit of sorts where
black tries to control the center with
D5
obviously here Queen H5 is a huge threat
so black usually follows up with Knight
F6 as far as I remember the best thing
to do in this position is to go D4
I don't know what the main line is Main
Line in quotes it's probably like D5 and
you kind of cling to the pawn of Bishop
D3
and even if you give the pawn away at a
later point you have the C5 Square as a
big Outpost
I think black is supposed to go E6 takes
takes and black gambits the pawn for
some development
so this is something I might investigate
later on my own I don't want to give you
a wrong line the biggest takeaways that
as I said at the start of the game your
mentality should not be oh I have to win
in 10 moves because then you make these
impulsive moves and you can actually get
in trouble
you should understand that these lines
are hard to refute now unless black of
course goes like King G6 right at some
point it crosses a line and then yeah
you have to go for checkmate
but we start by developing yeah like if
black had gone King G6 the funny thing
is this is still like plus two and the
best move according to the engine super
instructive is exactly how he played in
the game it's to play Bishop C4 and cut
off the king threatening made in one
black has to go E6 and now D5 still
working on opening the center
black is almost bust out here because if
black plays E5 who can spot based on the
patterns that we've already outlined
what is the best move here for white
very easy but very pretty you should
pause if you're watching on YouTube and
figure this out yeah it is to play D6 of
course cutting off the king
and I mean this is just a ridiculous
checkmate
so all of these lines get very one-sided
our opponent played it the best way that
he could Bishop C4
and Fisher B4 and D5 I think is a very
instructive moment so what would have
happened if instead we had played 92 why
did I reject this well it's because of
D5 and the kind of position that I don't
like is this one because D5 is now very
well protected and if we continue
developing black is already very close
to maybe not equalizing but getting a
playable position black is essentially
two moves away black just has to
complete the castle by hand
well the top engine move here is Knight
to E4 which is ridiculous
I would play Knight F4 yeah but rookie
eight
remember that when you're castling by
hand you don't always need to put the
Rook on the quote-unquote castling
square if you're already doing it you
might as well deploy The Rook onto like
an open file
and again Queen H5 King G8 is an empty
move black is still nasty it's a nasty
position but this is not the most that
we can do so we identified the proper
moment to push in the center okay 97.
now of course 92 Rock Cafe this I
explained during the game next critical
moment was here
so according to the chess.com engine
yeah d e is best but
um I was also considering the move
Knight to F4
the reason that I rejected this is
because of Bishop takes C3
and the point of Bishop C3 is to play
after BC the move e takes D5 which looks
terrifying but I couldn't see a way to
punish black directly I'll get to this
in a second
the reason black can't play Ed is
because after Knight D5 Knight D5 Knight
D5 we load up a discovery against the
black king there's too many threats
but after Bishop C3 white could try Pawn
takes E6 which I almost went for
and this looks like it works for white
because we're threatening Pawn takes
Pawn that's a discover check against the
King and then we take the bishop on C8
so that's what would happen if black
moves the bishop if plaque takes the
pawn we can actually play Knight takes
E6 looks chaotic but it's quite easy to
understand why this is winning now
there's a beautiful line
if black plays Queen takes D1 here's an
interesting question for you should
white plate Knight takes f8 or should
white play Rook takes D1 and keep the
tension what's the more accurate
conversion here
think about it try to calculate
now Knight takes C7 is an option but
that's not one of the options I'm giving
you
between these two moves which one is
best Rook do you want a knight of fate
so it's actually Knight f8 which is
counterintuitive because after King f8
Rook D1 you might say oh but black has
two pieces for a rook so the bishop can
move but you have to calculate one step
further this is a checkmate
this is the danger of putting the pawn
on F6 If instead you had taken on D1
first black can eliminate the Knight and
When the Smoke Clears white is up upon
and is overwhelmingly better but still
not as winning as we would be after
night of fate
but all of this is a moot point because
in this position black has a brilliant
defensive move and that is to play D5
and the point of this move is that it
seals off the possibility of a
discovered attack you have to respond
because the bishop is hanging
so you have to play Ed this black
Garner's attempt of bringing the bishop
back white has this Pawn failings in the
center but we're down a piece this is
far from convincing the position is
unclear
so that's why I didn't play de and by
extension that's why I didn't play
Knight F4 because after bced
probably we should take with a pawn and
black is able to freeze the pawn of the
move D6
and this is not as good for white as it
looks it looks amazing because you're
probably itching to put your knight on
E6 but if you do that prematurely
putting a Pawn on an outpost as
nimsovich wrote is actually not the best
right you want a piece to occupy an
outpost nimsovich in my system compared
this situation like you know you're
taking your opponent to the dentist and
getting their cavity filled right the
pawn is not an effective way most cases
to exploit a weakness because it almost
fills the hole you do your opponent
right it's like filling a cavity so
knowing that what would you suggest for
white here
and I still don't find this that
convincing for white but if you wanted
to maximize your advantage what would be
a way to apply that rule yeah it would
be to play rookie one in order to put a
rook on E6 so for example here here here
and rookie six I'm still not convinced
because the problem with putting a rook
on an outpost is that it's very easy to
chase that piece away
so
so probably what I would do is follow
the engine suggestion just Bishop to D3
loading up on the H7 pawn and
restricting the mobility of this Knight
of course if black gives away the light
skirt Bishop the moment that happens we
jump into E6 we win the exchange and
even if we didn't win the exchange the
Knight would be a beast
okay
but given the possibility of taking
first and then playing Knight F4 I
figured this is more straightforward
because here black simply cannot defend
upon
Knight bc6
and both Bishop E6 and 96 are good I
won't delve too deeply into this line
here white is up a pawn and in this
position black is forced to make this
awkward move and now we can jump in with
Knight P5 I think this would have been
more accurate that would be my guess I
think this position is just even more
overwhelming than Knight takes E6 but I
fell in love with the prospect of
getting a bishop pair the trade King h8
Knight T5 and our opponent found a very
nice response
so again if we had played Queen G4 the
scary Prospect is F5
now you might be looking at this and
saying what the heck is going on well
it's quite easy right this is an
undermining move because the pawn and E4
is overloaded it's undermining and
interference in one
right and it's good when you're a newer
player particularly and you see a move
like let's say during speeder and it
move confuses you are you like what how
what is going on try to break it down
into its component tactical
characterizations the first thing it
does is it severs the connection between
the queen and the bishop that's
interference
the second thing it does is it tries to
force the pawn out of E4 so that's decoy
or undermining because then the Knight
on D5 will hang after EF Knight takes D5
also the queen hangs so you can't take
the bishop because the queen hangs so it
also creates a one move threat after
Bishop F5 black and play Knight takes F5
and things get very messy here obviously
if you take the Knight black takes the
Knight and black is up a piece white can
actually maintain an advantage but it's
not by taking the bishop who can tell me
why why doesn't this work because on the
next move we simply play e takes F5
and here there is a map of the most
popular wrong answer most popular wrong
answer
yeah very good black takes with the
queen
noting the lateral x-rays cannot take
because of Queen G4
the tempting but wrong move would be
Knight F5 back to H6 this is an
excellent thought because it hits the
queen that this is common unfortunately
white just takes on H6 and black can
only take one piece at a time
yeah so tons of themes apparently
according to the engine white has some
Bishop F4 moving in the tactics white is
able to win the piece back but why would
you ever bog yourself down to this like
no need to calculate past F5 that's why
we just decided to make a very calm of
dropping the Knight back and defending
the bishop and again a lot of you were
worried about G5 but remember you can
take the queen that relinquishes the
attack on the bishop which turns G5 into
a useless one move threat now I think
this was a mistake by our opponent
giving us the D file but the position
was miserable anyway
G5 Knight C5 this is all very natural H4
best move
creating a second front attacking the
tip of the pawn chain
the point is after GH we have Bishop H6
this wins The Exchange and this by the
way is a very good Tactical
how should I put it tactical pattern to
be aware of a situation where you're
attacking your opponent's Rook on the
eighth rank with your Bishops and it's a
lot more common than you might think I
actually won a game against a strong I
am good friend of mine Casa Corley
we're using a technique like this that's
super easy to miss let me see if I can
dig up the game at least the start of
the game yes I can
so this is a similar technique where we
had a rogozin
and
Casa blunders he plays G3 Bishop F5 and
he plays Bishop G2 what did he blunder
in this position same exact concept
okay so yeah exactly this is easy Knight
takes C3 thanks Akila for bringing
everyone up to speed BC and Bishop jumps
out to A3 and The Rook is trap notice
that the Rook is dominated by the
Bishops if we're okay one Bang Casa was
forced to give up the exchange I took it
and I defended everything with Knight to
A5 and I ended up winning the game
so simple but but hopefully this this is
another feather in your cap and you can
see that it works the same way here
where after rookie 8 we have Bishop F7
but even better is to play Knight takes
F6 using three minor pieces to cover up
the Rook squares there's plenty of games
like this so that's how H4 works
tactically now we decided to open up the
H file and this idea of G3 King G2 and
Rook H1 is another
good tactical attacking idea to have in
your Arsenal let me see if I can find
off the top of my head a couple of
examples of this in real in IRL
games just give me 30 seconds
oh there we go this is literally exactly
what I freaking did watch this watch
this
this is exactly what I did in the game
just in a completely different position
which I always really like
this is a gligarich game now svets is
our gligarich was one of the strongest
one of the strongest players
of Yugoslavia he played Fisher I mean
I'm sure you've heard the name
okay so here we go
in this position licorice is playing
matanovich who's super strong and he
does exactly what we did
H4 so first he starts by challenging the
weak Pawn on G5 black does some crap
gliggerage brings his Queen up then he
takes on G5 the problem is if black
plays FG then this Pawn on E5 becomes a
big weakness so matanovich plays HD and
now you should already understand G3
King G2 and Rook H1 and by getting the
Rooks off the board gligarich is able to
ensure a winning end game and now he
plays a beautiful idea absolutely
beautiful geometry now now what you
should be itching to do is get the queen
to H1 but there is a lovely way to do
that without first bringing it back to
E1 King G1
and he opens up a pathway now the queen
threatens to jump into H7 so black has
to block it with his Bishop trade and
the queen infiltrates to h8 and it's a
winning Queen end game because of this
Pawn being an absolute monster so
gligerich just gets into a winning punt
end game and black resigns because or
black resigned after F4 what is the
winning move here for white who can tell
me like what is actually the winning
move here for white in this position
it's not GF this is a draw it's actually
F3 creating the pawn Cube yeah everybody
guessed it very nice because after all
of the trades
it should be intuitively apparent to why
this is winning because essentially you
will ultimately reach a situation
because black has no waiting moves where
white forces black into Zoo song it
doesn't matter how black tries to defend
for example if black goes here you could
even go King E4 King F6 and D6 and then
D7 very common technique and now you do
what's called shouldering where you just
forcibly toss the king away because
black is always going to be in zug's Von
and that's it black has to give away the
C Pawn
um so now had matanovic not played F4
had he played E4 and tried to create a
fortress gligarich would have used the
dark squares to infiltrate with his King
same thing black
ah so here you have to be very clever
though last question in the send game
how should white proceed here let's see
who learned from the pawn engine videos
yeah King T2
triangulation because if you go King E3
remember that white doesn't have pawn
moves either so you need this position
with black to move because then you'll
need to be able to infiltrate to F4 so
you go King to D2
King E5 like if black goes back then
King E3 and now blackheads and black
gets tossed away and shouldered distant
opposition yeah
so that didn't work and if blackhead
waited then gligarich would have done
the same thing F3 G4 and just carved his
way toward Black's position F4 G5 is
trousers and white spawns promote which
is why connected passwords are actually
worse than separated passers in Pawn n
games anyways this is all a cool bonus
just remember this idea of occupying the
H file G3 King G2 Rook H1
um I think this was a good illustration
all right
so
okay so the way the game proceeded okay
our opponent obviously like threw up
another throw away another Pawn
and the thing to understand here is that
after Rook B8 we go Bishop D5 Rook B2
Bishop B3 yet another pattern and now
this Rook is going to get trapped one or
the one way or the other way so in any
case
um our opponent we're looking G7 we drop
back the rest of the game is pretty
straightforward this threatens Bishop H6
and Bishop takes A7
we take a third Pawn C6 Bishop E6 no
need to take this pawn and allow Rook C8
related Shenanigans because it's easy to
just fall into like material mode and
then before you know it you blunder
something ironically that's always what
happens when you get too greedy
you know you disarm the only source of
activity that black has which is this
Pawn takes takes back to E3 notice the
role of this bishop how it's defending
and attacking
we take another Pawn we go back to E6
drop down to B3 trapping The Rook
threatening Bishop to D4 black prevents
that we use the alternate route Bishop
C1 and Bishop H6
so pretty straightforward game
conceptually speaking couple key
takeaways obviously what I said about
punishing these openings don't try to do
it all at once
oftentimes the key is to decide when to
open up the center and here we decided
it based on lack threatening to occupy
the center themselves so we decided to
strike first right so don't be dogmatic
about okay I need to develop every
single piece but you definitely need to
develop some pieces
then try to cash in your advantage right
you have a big space Advantage we cash
it in by exploiting a specific and
focusing in on a specific Pawn weakness
don't be afraid to trade Queens if
that's what it takes for you to start
winning material right the queen trade
here would not have heard uh hurt us at
all in any way in fact it would have
helped us by giving us the D file and
then the rest of the game was pretty
much straightforward good idea to play
G3 and King G2 another one to file into
Your Arsenal and then not being overly
greedy but taking the free stuff
and that's it alright guys thank you
very much I will be back for the second
title Tuesday in three hours
hopefully and I will see you guys then
so hope you enjoyed the uh the game
we've got some content now
wait is it just chess yeah it's just
chess
okay see ya
[Music]